hey ron
good to see ya
what's your pirate last year
yes this is my halloween costume
it's halloween
i'm surprised you didn't put on a
costume i was going to sir but then i
decided
screw that jazz
well i'm the only one who ever dresses
up no one ever gets my costume and they
make fun of me so i'm done
these people don't deserve my dress-up
gifts
charles
seriously no costume what the hell
charles where's your halloween spirit
but you guys always make fun of me i
have never once insulted you in my life
especially vis-a-vis your appearance
yeah man we always love your costumes
remember last year when you came as that
person and or thing yes i do remember
sir permission to sprint to my car and
get my emergency costume does it matter
if i say no
[Music]
bam bam boom
what the what why are you dressed up you
look like an idiot but yeah what are you
supposed to be a sassy car mechanic no
come on he's clearly the rejected
pop-tarts mascot harry pop-tart i am not
you know who i am squad that's enough
you're making boyle for bad on purpose
he's elvis yes elvis stoico the canadian
figure skater no in case you can't read
my my poker face
we will be reviewing our sales policies
i have 10 seconds to explain them or
this whole place blows up magruva
your costume is fantastic
i set away for it in july from a catalog
oh no don't don't don't
okay
oh
man
okay i have to fire somebody
it's totally okay that you didn't wear a
costume
i did i'm a straight person
hey sorry i'm late see
my gold record from that novelty party
song
spooky scary points becoming men
[Music]
look who decided to join the party bro
that's awesome
where's your costume
honey he's wearing a costume he's going
as lame
that's a pretty good costume actually
this year i decided to really get into
the spirit of halloween
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
it may have been the costliest decision
i've ever made
my greased up head went into the pumpkin
no problem but it won't budge i can't
get it out
try again
i mean i could try destroying the
pumpkin no no no but as jim and i
discovered
no
any blow to the pumpkin itself could
prove fatal to me
at first i drove myself crazy thinking
about the things i should have done
differently
i never should have played that joke on
aaron keyboard never should have
hollowed out this damn pumpkin in the
first place
but then i realized i was being silly
i mean the pumpkin should rot off of my
head in a month or two
you're the uh the lady in here the usa
oh great attention boys and ghouls nope
every halloween i dress up in an amazing
costume and you never get what i am no
we get what you are an adult man who
enjoys dress-up very funny rosa
this year that won't be a problem
because you're gonna pick my costume ah
come on
uh
miss pac-man's nipple no that's brown
why would you know that to be or not to
be not to be thank you
ah
joan of arc rod stewart martha stewart
he-man master of the universe i got it
gay robin hood
yes
oh my gosh that's what it is
could you for once just let us enjoy a
party instead of making it about all
your issues
[Applause]
[Music]
i present to you the rational consumer
as it were
[Music]
i don't like your tone look they were
sold out of all the other costumes okay
i think we all live in the real world
here let's not pretend to be unaware of
what sells in this office
but italians are so much more than just
um spaghetti and meatballs from the
beginning of time white women have
honored us with their contributions to
science and the arts a bell rang out
through the city of dolores
gong
gong
known as the land beyond the forest
transylvania is rich in natural splendor
and mineral resources eleanor roosevelt
joy behar marie curie madonna brainy
smurf's special talent is his brain
there's the sistine chapel
uh penne arabiata you pour the vinegar
in
and the lava comes out
[Music]
jokey smurf he tells jokes he's funny
he's the funny one gerrymandering may
present the the most grave threat to our
democracy
the venice canals
in uh mozzarella sticks if you look back
to the midterm election results of 2006
shoot your web oh
no i'm i'm not uh spider-man shoot it
anyway
whip
nice
and a clown
i'm jigsaw idiot you're not as scary as
a book face over there
yes i am the popular social networking
site known as bookface
i can't help being a gorgeous fiend
it's just the card i drew
what in the hell
are you wearing
we're on their turf juliet we have to
walk the walk of a true night stalker
night stuffer he's right look around
you're the fish out of water here
because they're all pretending to be
dead sean or perhaps it is us
who pretend to be alive blue shirt
badge
night stick
you are a policewoman
yep you're a regular sherlock holmes i
solved that mystery before you did
okay this is fun
andy you are ufc legend chuck liddell
that's right
girl from the ring
to me sherlock holmes is literally the
greatest character in the western canon
smart intuitive handsome
replaces pasty british frailty with
superhuman physical fitness and you get
sherlock traeger
i didn't realize that everybody here
dresses up every year me neither
it's halloween
that is really really good timing
you